we're asked to identify the percent
amount and base in this problem and they
asked us 150 is 25% of what number so
another way to think about it is 25% 25%
times some number so I'll do 25% in
yellow and 25% times some number times
number times some number is equal to is
equal to 150 is equal to 150 so the
percent is pretty easy to spot we have a
25% right over here so this is going to
be the percent that is the percent and
we're multiplying the percent times some
base number so this right over here is
the base so we have the percent times
the base we have the percent times the
base is equal to some amount is equal to
is equal to some is equal to some amount
and you could try to solve this in your
head this is essentially saying 25% of
some number 25% times some number is
equal to 150 if it helps we can rewrite
this as as 0.25 which is the same thing
as 25% 0.25 times some number times some
number is equal to 150 and what an
interesting thing is just think about
should that number be larger or smaller
than 150 well if we only take 25% of
that number if we only take 25
hundredths of that number if we only
take 1/4 of that number because that's
what 25 hundredths is or that's what 25%
is we get 150 so this number needs to be
larger than hundred 50 in fact it has to
be larger than 150 by 4 and to actually
figure out what the number is we can
actually multiply since this what's on
the left hand side is equal to the right
hand side if we want to solve this we
can multiply both sides by 4 if we say
look we have some value over here we're
going to multiply it by 4 in order for
it to still be equal we have to multiply
150 times 4 4 times 0.25 or 4 times 25
percent or 4 times 1/4
worth this is just going to be one that
is just going to be one and we're going
to get our number is equal to 150 times
four or it is equal to 600 and that
makes sense
twenty-five percent of 600 is 150 1/4 or
600 is 150